音出る曲と目覚める旭堂ずにかけてどっちが勝つかやって採用
5番はウズ3節をです朝鮮寝巻きでございますもんねじゃんでしょもう
極限に疲れてましてなんならもう秒で寝れると思うんですけど世の中屋根れる曲と寝れ
ない曲があると思うんですよねで曲っていうのならこう
脳の右脳傘の丘
なが響くヒーリングミュージックとかそういうアンビエント系能楽っていうのかな
俺は俺だったら寝やすい曲っていうのがあるんでそれ聞くと本土でれるんですよ
寧々家西曲っていうの対局にロックとかなどメタルパッドというかコーナーかっっ
うわぁ
みたいでうるさい曲あるんですけどもあれを聞いてれたさせにねこんな極限にね上状態
に今から出るんですけども果たして寝る曲と出れない曲をどうずに流すのどちらも勝つ
のかという時はやっていこうと思います
できるまでたいです明日も朝早いんでもう僕は味噌は何だろうねれる曲が断然勝って
ほしいんですけども寝れないジョブどうぞ音がでかいのでちょっとわかんないよねと
いうわけで音のバランスの調整も含め僕が直感的にもう絶対音や垂直だっていうのと
絶対に入れない曲だっていうのをもう僕メドレーで作っておいたんでこの2つ約1時間
40分くらい服があるんですよ
はもうこれは a に流し続けて僕は私は寝れるのが出れないのか
kenso していきたいと思いますちなみにエアコンをガンガンつけてって全部気を
付けてるんでめちゃくちゃ出やすい状態でございます果たしてどっちが勝つのでしょう
か
今回使用する音楽はあなたにリラックスでーしょん効果をもたらす素敵なれる音楽をご
用意いたしまし
たメロディーがあるチョクトない曲を織り交ぜ
多角的な視点から睡眠を促しております
自分のベティ大一番から始まりアニュー匹に
アスターさんら5 c down the
ぽいツリーオプスヘアーズ
様々な音楽であなたを快適な睡眠へと誘うこと間違いない
音楽選出になっておりますごゆるりと音楽をお楽しみくださいませ
うわあああああ
too re re re re re re ペイオン郷中きたて全部の曲はお前の
魂
ソウルに来るジャグラー
ぽい前座ブレイザーろくっ急所メッセっ
枚直感字バッグ i feel life
おっちゃりああーっ
全力どんだけで大場よ絶対見方ねー
ロックンロールイズマイライフ
ああああああああ
かよでは早速寝ていこうかと思いますおやすみなさいまし
女医
せーのっ
[音楽]
ha
ブーツ税
おっ t 4
[音楽]
すまん
平和曲言わん所具材
[音楽]
ん
ああああああ
アイゼンゼネ様像は姉ちゃんねえよ
続くうーんなって寝れません
[音楽]
ん
濡れませんぞメッツてれるのに快適なのねー
エイ
[音楽]
そっかーキャッチャー
me
[音楽]
アーちゃんとんでね無理な胸メジャー混ぜねーよ
結果買ってれだへ直が練れば
センっ
[音楽]
car
uh
うううう
me
re ああああ